welcome to this video shake all
McCarrick keep getting opponents that I
never played am quite amazing okay not
not the NIMS Oh again let's do let's go
for the Queen's Indian I don't really
know it don't really know this opening
well but she I just want to have a
little bit of a variety okay this is a
line that i actually have played with
black at some point quite interesting
black tries to fight for the dark
squares ok d5 ok you can play a 25 but
and i never did that and I was plated
with bishop to c6 but that's not bad the
way it he is he's playing it so
certainly certainly possible I'm trying
to fight against them c5 move if I can
hear ya i've got quincy six-hour thought
butty to hangs hmm ok ok maybe start
with devils and to go from from here
Quincy six I wonder i still wonder this
is maybe a move let's five not possible
it's got but c5 i can still just take
some came
maybe Bishop 70 I have there should be
seven looks good now
yeah if it's possible it's good
definitely getting rid of this this
problem take sia what is he doing bishop
you for me and maybe take first think
later ok so before i have got knight c6
but this is not leading anywhere i
probably have to get the Queen out of
this hmm yeah the special bond is 60 a
little bit of a nuisance if I've night
f5 and Roxy one is some is a natural way
to continue yeah as measured e5 Knight
f5 and rook FC one is next
Oh interesting didn't think about that
one can still play B form
hmm can I make it not sure you take a
couple of times he will take you take
what the rook at the end of the night is
also hanging with knight c6 as a move
hmm but it doesn't seem to work
yeah be four tix he be who I don't
really think I can play before it's kind
of strange but not a happy movie but I
really couldn't make it work yeah now
I'm intending to play before
a technically tricky position I'm not
really sure that be four is this even a
serious threat at all but if I don't do
that the whole thing is totally
pointless so I'm going to play it yeah
this is this is one of the one of the
points and Bishop to c4 might be might
be an additional one
but at least he is catching up on time a
little bit so it's looks if a special c4
move I can take it and then take on b7
just prolly not bad now I have some
ideas rook c6c 6 Queen a 7b five and the
bishop has strapped anyway b5 first now
that this doesn't look so great nights
is six or so ever interesting yeah this
is good right a5 and yet this is just
this is just a quite Elementary double
attack
hmm time warning yeah I know I know just
keep the tube ball maybe can I can get
the night back into the game
yeah taking e6
I'm sure how good this really is this a
knight adventure here now this costs too
much time and where are my pieces I kind
of kind of ugly on this side of the
board especially considering that i've
got an extra porn on the queenside yeah
I really have to get stuff back down now
it's okay I don't think I did anything
exceptionally exceptionally stupid check
this a pawn my ipod is also quite quick
you cannot go see to now check check
check check mate oh yeah if it was close
yeah very very tough position the
scallop position is just complicated it
looks like i have some issues here with
this thing with this pawn they also
would like to look a little bit at this
kind of phase of the game it looks like
a very normal position it certainly
something that
it's probably it's maybe not a book
position but something that just make
some some kind of sense this is
surprised me but ok it seems to be
technically justified yeah yeah of
course I spent far too much time at one
minute something I didn't want to play
this passive move but I have to I guess
now before yeah this is turns the table
no I'm quite quite good shape am yeah
yeah yeah I'm just much better but what
I did did wrong is I mean various things
here I should take oops and take and now
here this is no much better in
comparison now e5 is not possible I mean
maybe I didn't do anything super
terrible he call that quickly got the
pieces back but at one point they really
really were often though on the
queenside and here they poorness
promoting yeah it was a matter of
seconds iam okay thanks for watching